Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new spider-man 3 doctor strange 2 video
marvel just dropped some of the best news so we'll
break it all down explain what's going on with all
this multiverse spider-verse stuff if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos they're going to be filming doctor
strange 2 and spider-man 3 at the same time in
a couple weeks so this will all make sense pretty
soon i'm sorry i'm confused as to the relationship
here what what is he your ward no i'm peter by
the way doctor strange oh you're using their made
up names um i'm spider-man then but we'll do an
amazon giveaway all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and leave all your predictions for
spider-verse in spider-man 3. starting with the
big stuff first though number five if you didn't
see the news earlier this morning deadline variety
hollywood reporter the rap all the biggest
hollywood trades the real big publications
are reporting the benedict cumberbatch doctor
strange will be in spider-man 3 and spider-man 3
will cross over with the doctor strange 2 movie
which is now the next marvel movie right after
spider-man 3 whereas before the virus shut down it
was actually supposed to be the other way around
with doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness
happening right before the events of spider-man 3.
it provides a better explainer for why
jamie foxx's electro from the andrew
garfield amazing spider-man movies is coming
back as a sinister 6 villain in spider-man 3
and it explains a little more about how Wandavisionin those episodes of scarlet witch
mess up the multiverse because<span style="font-size: 18.7px;">Wandavision</span>is
also supposed to cross over with doctor strange
2 scarlet witch will be a main character during
that movie we'll be getting the<span style="font-size: 18.7px;">Wandavision</span>
episodes later this year so we won't have to wait
too long to see how that happens the news reports
though are also quoting that doctor strange now
is supposed to step in and serve as sort of a
new mentor for spider-man and spider-man 3. the
same way that iron man was a mentor to him before
he died in avengers end game sort of connecting
back to their meeting during avengers infinity war
like you're the guy from that ship and the guy
who did all the weird circles before we fought
thanos and came back to life so in spider-man
3 we're still going to be using our made up
names everybody posts all your memes number four
doctor strange two is also being directed by sam
raimi mr spider-man himself from the tobey
maguire spider-man movies really excited to
see what he does with the movie there was a brief
period a long time ago when sam raimi even tried
to get a doctor strange movie made before
marvel studios became the big powerhouse that
it was today he even dropped a huge doctor
strange easter egg during spider-man 2.
a guy named otto octavius winds up with
eight limbs what are the odds huffman
what are we gonna call this guy
uh uh doctor octopus that's crap
uh science squid crap doctor strange that's
pretty good but it's taken wait wait i got it
doctor octopus but i like it of course you do it's
funny to see how things have turned out in the way
that kevin foggy and the mcu are trading so hard
on the multiverse and now spider-verse easter eggs
so we already got the seeds of the mcu
multiverse back during the tobey maguire
spider-man movies even though when you asked
sam raimi about that scene he said that he had
no idea things would eventually turn out the way
they did with the mcu and all the marvel movies
number three though the reason why it's important
that doctor strange 2 is crossing over with
spider-man 3 is because of the multiverse theme of
the marvel phase 4 movies they're going with all
the marvel phase 4 movies will somehow incorporate
the multiverse repercussions of what scarlet witch
does during<span style="font-size: 18.7px;">Wandavision</span>that's the whole point
of those marvel disney plus series being avengers
endgame spin-offs is that they're supposed to
star the movie actors and they're supposed to
cross over with the movies and influence the plot
of future movies i'll explain the<span style="font-size: 18.7px;">Wandavision</span>
stuff in a second but as a result of this new
confirmation now we can also say spider-man 3
will also have some multiverse elements probably
not quite as crazy as what we'll see during
doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness because
multiverse is literally in the title of that movie
spider-man 3 will still mostly be just a plain
old spider-man movie with him dealing with the
fallout of mysterio leaking his secret identity
and blaming him falsely for his death so the
electro twist with jamie foxx's character coming
back is probably the biggest type of multiverse
twist that i'm expecting in early theory jamie
foxx claimed on his instagram account that he
was definitely coming back as electro but they
wouldn't be blue this time he quickly deleted that
post the marvel snipers got to him like you're
not allowed to reveal any of these details yet be
quiet so he deleted his post but we screencapped
it before he did you thought we wouldn't notice
but we did but a lot of people saw his post
about not being blue this time and assumed
that that meant that they wouldn't be using a
multiverse twist and he would just be a version of
mcu electro and it wouldn't really be connected
to the andrew garfield amazing spider-man movies
but now because of the direct doctor strange
2 crossover and confirmed multiverse theme my
early theory is before we get more information
about this because they won't start filming for
a couple more weeks is that electro will look
more like comic book electro's classic costume
little more authentic to the original version
but he'll still be a version of the character
who fought a version of spider-man that looks like
andrew garfield spider-man in another universe so
there'll still be some spider-verse easter eggs
and you can argue whether or not that canonizes
the andrew garfield amazing spider-man movies
to the spider-verse of the mcu but the other
really cool easter egg here is that number two
speaking of electro spider-verse easter eggs fun
fact energy crosses the multiverse all the time
they've already been doing it a lot in the mcu
remember the way they explained how magic in
the mcu works during the doctor strange movie
the same way that the thor movies also explain
some of their more advanced technology just
science that you haven't learned to explain yet
during the dr strange movie the ancient one taught
doctor strange that the power from their spells
are pulled from other dimensions and that's also
where the dormammu dark dimension dark energy
twist came from the ancient one in kaiselius his
followers were pulling dark energy from dormammu's
dimension across the multiverse to gain even more
power so is them manipulating energy pulling it
into the main mcu universe from other dimensions
electro from amazing spider-man 2 became a being
of pure energy so it'd be way easier for him to
cross between universes of the multiverse they
also used the energy explainer during avengers
end endgame to travel the multiverse time and
space as well and during ant-man and the wasp
they use quantum energy so doctor strange isn't
using quantum energy when he's weaving spells it's
a different kind of energy but it's the same basic
principle energy crosses between dimensions of the
multiverse in the mcu much easier i think the real
question though about electro and spider-verse
easter eggs and spider-man 3 is how he actually
winds up on the mcu version of earth is it an
accident is it on purpose but usually when we
talk about spider-man movies and spider-man style
stories usually it winds up being big accidents
like oops then you have a big one-liner and some
quips from spider-man so number one going back
to<span style="font-size: 18.7px;">Wandavision</span>how is this all going to work
starting with<span style="font-size: 18.7px;">Wandavision</span>we know they're
dealing with the multiverse based on the
<span style="font-size: 18.7px;">Wandavision</span>trailer footage it seems like what's
going on during that is that scarlet witch is
living inside a bubble alternate reality where she
controls reality and can change things on the fly
and that's how she brings vision and her children
to life that's also why everything looks like it's
the different eras of the tv shows and the sitcoms
because it's her warping reality jumping through
tv decades and sitcoms but early theory she loses
control of that house of m style because it was a
big house of m easter egg during the trailer in
that story the alternate reality where mutants
were supreme wound up crumbling around her so that
might happen in the mcu making her go even crazier
trying to save her twin children and and while
she's doing that she winds up cracking the fabric
of the entire multiverse around the mcu earth
then that would be a really easy way to explain
how characters from other universes and things
start to bleed into our mcu earth influencing
all the rest of the marvel phase 4 movies then
that's probably why doctor strange gets involved
wanda what did you do to the multiverse and why
doctor strange 2 is literally titled multiverse
of madness larger more powerful cosmic villains
probably take advantage of what scarlet witch
tries to do and then come into our dimension then
because of the way they've reordered some of the
marvel movies during marvel phase 4 we continue to
see the after effects of that multiverse conflict
continue during spider-man 3 giving way to
spider-verse easter eggs and helping set the stage
for spider-man to cross over with venom in a
future movie later on that'll be a separate sony
thing so it does make sense that they'd want to
tease spider-verse and explain that in live action
before spider-man has a major crossover with venom
then the venom 2 movie is also coming out before
doctor strange 2 it would also explain how tom
holland could appear in a cameo scene during
that as well just more multiverse spider first
after effects then when we get to doctor strange 2
that's where doctor strange mostly cleans up the
whole multiverse mess with the help of scarlet
witch who's a main character during doctor strange
too it also now because doctor strange is supposed
to be a mentor to spider-man and spider-man 3 with
all this multiverse spider-verse stuff going on
it also might mean that spider-man might
cameo during doctor strange too the marvel
sony sharing deal was for spider-man 3 in one
more mystery mcu crossover movie for spider-man
doctor strange too just might wind up being
that mystery movie but post all your theories
in the comments below what other multiverse
spider burst easter eggs do you want to see
during spider-man 3. i know everybody wants
some pizza time everyone wants to see toby
mcguire's spider-man cameo everyone wants to see
some andrew garfield amazing spider-man cameos
there is that tobey spider-man costume inside
the morbius trailer but there are a lot of
rumors about how that's explained during the movie
we'll have to wait a little bit longer to find out
obviously that doesn't get into any of the
sinister six stuff that they're setting up
during spider-man 3 because that's where jamie
foxx's electro character comes in too he was an og
sinister six team member but as they start to
film spider-man 3 in the next couple of weeks
they'll be in new york city doing that so if
you live in new york city you might be able
to spot them filming out on the street so i will
be doing more spider-man 3 videos as we get more
behind the scenes clips and teasers about what's
actually going on during the movie but leave all
your requests and big questions in the comments
below everyone click here for my spider-man 3
andrew garfield electro video and click here
for my new trailer for the boys season 2 episode
8 that's the finale thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!